let's how about your old spice adds
those are fantastic thank you and one of
them you dressed as a woman and I think
we have a picture of this here and it's
interesting because what would you think
of yourself as an attractive woman
well no not at all well you know what
this is the thing I am the only man in
the world who puts a dress on and looks
more manly there's no fee melody
anywhere yes you become yes you're
maleness will break through if I address
as a woman I become a woman when I dress
as a man I become a woman but you
unbelievable I am in touch with my
feminine side okay I gotta say that I'm
very very sensitive like you know one
thing I had to realize as a man is that
you can be too manly you know what I
mean I know yeah yeah it's bestest alone
you were know that was a guy employer
right but you can beat you manly you can
beat you up and I have four daughters
and a wife and the whole thing and then
I had to realize how to be more
sensitive and I'll put I have a little
tea party with the kids and I'm like and
you and I have a little grandbaby was a
granddaughter and it makes you just more
you know I had to be in touch with that
that's France now is it you you like to
get some waxing done I'm in touch with
my feminine side yeah so I go get my
legs waxed I love the feeling of smooth
legs I used to shave like with a razor
and then it would leave stubble and my
wife is like and now it's like hey
you think women like women like it when
you have smooth I said my wife wife
loves nice moving jugo de you go and you
go to a waxing so I go to a waxing salon
and let me tell you at first the pain
was incredible but you get used to pay
you it's well as the I put my headphones
on and after a while every woman in here
knows you can use to it right
you do not men wanna go but but I have
to say as a man I tell all guys you
gotta get hit in the face at least once
in your life okay because the fear of
getting hit in the face is worse than
actually getting hit in the face so the
same thing with what waxing it's the
fear of the way just let it go realize
like you've been punched in the face
before I was punched yes I was bad I
like that you just assume now-now Conan
just given your personality on something
you've been punched out of your
you